Gleadell is a large grain trading business,...
...also a large seller of seed and fertiliser to UK farmers.
We are owned by Toepfer International...
...and InVivo, who are respectively based in Hamburg and Paris...
...and are large international trading entities.
We import and we export throughout the EU...
...and into the Mediterranean and occasionally further afield.
The grain we trade is wheat,...
...both for feed production, i.e. feed wheat, biscuit manufacture, flour milling.
We also trade malting barley for beer.
We also are large traders in oilseed rape,...
...which nowadays goes into two markets: one is vegetable oils...
...and the other is biodiesel production.
Also, we trade pulses, both for human consumption and for feed,...
...and they trade internationally throughout the Mediterranean.
Volatile markets mean that farmers can get it wrong just as much as they can get it right,...
...and getting it wrong can cost them,...
...you know, 50, 60 pounds a ton on 3,000 tons of wheat, it's a big difference.
So, we're selling our advisory services to farmers in return for doing their business.